estos automovilistas fueron sorprendidos
cuando recorrían ni Pro una fábrica de
propulsores de cohete fue alcanzada por
un misil Ruso causando fuertes estragos
las autoridades locales dicen que más de
una docena de personas resultaron
heridas en esta última Ráfaga de ataques
aéreos que perjudicaron la ciudad
portuaria estratégica de Odessa así como
zaporilla ni pro y la capital kiev a
medida que se acerca el invierno los
ataques se dirigieron a la
infraestructura energética de Ucrania la
capital ya ha tenido su primera capa de
nieve y está experimentando temperaturas
bajo cero
los sitios civiles son el objetivo
principal al volar centrales eléctricas
y otras instalaciones energéticas Rusia
está librando una guerra contra la
electricidad y la calefacción para las
personas los ataques se producen después
de que más de 100 misiles cayeran en
territorio ucraniano el pasado 15 de
noviembre así como una explosión en
Polonia que mató a dos personas y generó
temores ante una posible escalada del
conflicto a nivel mundial ya que Polonia
es miembro de la otan el presidente
celenski insiste en que el misiles de
procedencia rusa posición que contrasta
con la de las autoridades polacas y que
es avalada en un principio por la otan y
Estados Unidos una investigación inicial
concluyó que lo más probable es que se
trate de un proyectil que hace parte de
la batería de defensa aérea de Ucrania